but think about this when it comes to an
inherently deadly weapon uh nobody
argues that guns are potentially deadly
weapons that kill tens of thousands of
Americans every year Congress actually
voted to make it harder for public
health experts to conduct research into
gun violence made it harder to collect
data and facts and develop strategies to
reduce gun violence even after San
Bernardino they've refused to make it
harder for terror suspects who can't get
on a plane to buy semi-automatic weapons
that's not right that can't be right so
the gun lobby may be holding Congress
hostage right now but they cannot hold
America hostage we do not have to accept
this carnage
now I want to be clear Congress still
needs to act the folks in this room will
not rest until Congress does
because once Congress gets on board with
common-sense gun safety measures we can
reduce gun violence a whole lot more but
we also can't wait until we have a
Congress that's in line with the
majority of Americans there are actions
within my legal authority that we can
take to help reduce gun violence to save
more lives actions that protect our
rights and our kids after Sandy Hook Joe
and I worked together with our teams and
we put forward a whole series of
executive actions to try to tighten up
the existing rules and systems that we
had in place but today we want to take
it a step further so let me outline what
we're going to be doing number one
anybody in the business of selling
firearms must get a license and conduct
background checks or be subject to
criminal prosecutions
it doesn't matter whether you're doing
it over the Internet or at a gun show
it's not where you do it but what you do
we're also expanding background checks
to cover violent criminals who try to
buy some of the most dangerous firearms
by hiding behind trusts and corporations
and various cutouts we're also taking
steps to make the background check
system more efficient under the guidance
of Jim combing the FBI and our deputy
director I'm Brandon 2af ATF we're going
to hire more folks to process
applications faster and we're going to
bring an outdated background check
system into the 21st century
and these steps will actually lead to a
smoother process for law-abiding gun
owners a smoother process for
responsible gun dealers a stronger
process for protecting the people from
the public from dangerous people so
that's number one number two we're going
to do everything we can to ensure the
smart and effective enforcement of gun
safety laws that are already on the
books which means we're going to add 200
more ATF agents and investigators we're
going to require firearms dealers to
report more or lost more lost or stolen
guns on a timely basis we're working
with advocates to protect victims of
domestic abuse from gun violence where
too often
because we're too often people are not
getting the protection that they need
number three we're going to do more to
help those suffering from mental illness
get the help that they need
I profile mass shootings tend to shine a
light on those few mentally unstable
people who inflict harm on others but
the truth is that nearly two and three
gun deaths are from suicides so a lot of
our work is to prevent people from
hurting themselves that's why we made
sure that the Affordable Care Act also
known as Obamacare finally
under that loft made sure that treatment
for mental health was covered the same
as treatment for any other illness
that's why we're going to invest five
hundred million dollars to expand access
to treatment across the country
it's also why we're going to ensure that
federal mental health records are
submitted to the background check system
and remove barriers that prevent States
from reporting relevant information if
we can continue two distinct mental
health issues get folks proper care and
fill gaps in the background check system
then we can spare more families the pain
of losing a loved one to suicide and for
those in Congress who so often rush to
blame mental illness for mass shootings
as a way of avoiding action on guns
here's your chance to support these
efforts put your money where your mouth
number four we're going to boost gun
safety technology now today many gun
injuries and deaths are the result of
legal guns that were stolen or misused
or discharged accidentally in 2013 alone
more than 500 people lost their lives to
gun accidents and that includes 30
children younger than 5 years old and
the greatest most technologically
advanced nation on earth there is no
reason for this we need to develop new
technologies that make gun safer if we
can set it up so you can't unlock your
phone unless you got the right
fingerprint why can't we do the same
thing for our guns
if there's an app that can help us find
a missing tablet which happens to me
often the older I get
if we can do it for your iPad there's no
reason we can't do it with a stolen gun
if a child can't open a bottle aspirin
we should make sure that they can't pull
a trigger on a gun